it's the most wonderful time of the year
it's called Khan's Jedi masked with a
special sneak preview of what to look
forward to in the movie world
[Applause]
this year's comic-con is a little
different from years before a lot of TV
and the dismal three major studios are
intense this year but and there's a bus
so Studios attending are huge and we're
absolutely getting big news and big
reveals specifically in the superhero
world kicking things off Thursday
morning at 11:30 a.m. local time is 20th
Century Fox and they've got a heck of a
lot to discuss filming is currently
underway for New Mutants Deadpool 2 and
x-men Dark Phoenix now the hyper
Deadpool 2 is already there but the
studio will need to do a push on new
moons and Dark Phoenix to get more
people excited outside of the superhero
verse Fox also has Kingsman the Golden
Circle one of my most highly anticipated
movies of the year and it's right around
the corner hitting theaters this fall
and we haven't seen much beyond that
initial trailer so there should be a
large push for that on Thursday now
let's move all the way to Saturday 11:30
a.m. local time is the warner brothers
hall age panel which means since that
inner DC movies and after the success of
Wonder Woman my excitement for DC movies
is back on Ben Affleck gal gadot Jason
Momoa Ezra Miller and ray Fisher will be
there talking Justice League plus we're
going to get an early look at the solo
Aquaman movie Warner Brothers also
revealed Steven Spielberg and the cast
of ready player one will be on the panel
as well as the much talked-about Blade
Runner 2049 which will include Harrison
Ford and Ryan Gosling as panelists one
thing that was really hoping for that's
not on the Warner Brothers agenda is two
Raiders my favorite action hero of all
time and I want as much as I can
possibly get out of this movie so
fingers crossed this will maybe be one
of the surprise factors of the panel
maybe moving on to the headliner of the
weekend with a 90-minute panel Marvel
Studios they're coming fresh off me 23
so we're probably looking at four
Ragnarok and black panther also on their
slates Avengers and
or ant-man and the wasp and of course
Captain Marvel I'm hoping for a world
Captain Marvel we know free Larsson
playing her I've seen concept art when I
visited Marvel Studios it's early but
hey it's entirely possible after Sunday
I'll be spending entirely too much money
on the show floor before racing back to
LA to watch Game of Thrones so tell me
your hopes wishes and dreams and
predictions for San Diego comic-con in
the comments you can tweet me and follow
me along all weekend long I'll be there
and I was plenty of updates for you here
on TV
[Applause]
[Music]